- How do you say the word G-I-F?
- I say JIF.
- G-I-F you pronounce JIF?
- Yes.
- This is the wrongest
thing that a person can do.
(lighthearted music)
- I say GIF. Some people say
JIF, like a bunch of dummies.
- Yeah, JIF, it's not Jiffy peanut butter.
- JIF, yeah, I call it a JIF.
- Like I, wait, you would call it a JIF?
- No, it's GIF. If you say it
any other way, you're wrong.
- I've heard, like, computer
people say JIF before.
- It's kind of like gift,
it's just missing the T.
- But like, is GIF short for something?
- GIF, Graphics Interchange
Format. That makes sense.
- Nobody says jraphics.
- Graphics is a hard G.
- So many words are not pronounced the way
they're supposed to be.
- Which is fine,
but this word should be pronounced GIF.
- Then you should've used a J.
- If you coin an abbreviation,
you don't get to coin how it's pronounced.
- JIF is fine, but it doesn't seem right.
- I'm just gonna call JPEGs GPEGs now.
- People can say GIF, people can say JIF,
people can say GEEF,
or whatever they want.
- GEEF.
- I mean, I don't care what people do.
- Let us know in the
comments what you think.
- Well, here I say GIF, and so.
- In private, in Kenny's bedroom.
- And here's the only place I use Giphy.
I like whisper it to myself
after I talk to somebody.
(laughs)
At my desk, I'm like, "Oh
yeah, did you see that GIF?
"That was really good."
Then it's like, "JIF."